problema 39 este problema nos dice que
para ordenado de vértices de fx es igual
a x cuadrada más 6 x + 6 x 5 ahora
buscando vértices de parábolas hay una
fórmula que es menos b sobre 2a pero tal
vez olvides esto cuando tengas unos 30
años o en una en un par de semanas así
que el propósito de esto no es sólo para
pasar un examen de álgebra y ya sino
para que aprendas álgebra y luego
aprender cálculo si quieres y así de una
forma sencilla poder sacar cuáles son
sus puntos máximos y mínimos tal vez
pero de hecho hay una forma intuitiva de
poder hacer esto sólo con álgebra y lo
que tenemos que hacer es sólo escribirlo
en esa forma así que tenemos que fx es
igual aa por x menos algo no se ve todo
esto al cuadrado
más y luego sabemos que el vértice pasa
donde x es igual a veces cierto pues si
miras a esta parábola se puede escribir
todo de esta forma y si dices ok este
término de por aquí va a ser siempre
positivo por lo que el punto mínimo de
esta parábola es cuando este término es
igual a cero y esto pasa cuando x es
igual a veces cierto entonces nuestro
vértice sería igual al punto b como
hacer así que hagamos esto aunque en
realidad podrías memorizar que esto es
menos b sobre 2 a estaría bien que
tuvieras la intuición entonces tenemos x
cuadrada más 6 x más 5 y estoy dejando
ese espacio porque vamos a esencialmente
completar cuadrados entonces es como si
tuvieras lo siguiente como si tuvieras x
+ al cuadrado y al desarrollar el
binomio es igual a x cuadrada más 2 x
masa cuadrada donde x cuadra de esa x
cuadrada
ese día 6 entonces quién sería
sería igual a 3 pues 3 por 2 6 la mitad
de 6 es tres y tres al cuadrado es 9 y
entonces tenemos completado aquí nuestro
cuadrado pero no puedes simplemente
sumar un 9 de un lado de la ecuación
pues lo que tendríamos que hacer sería
sumar de ambos lados para no alterar
dicha ecuación por lo que si sumamos 9
por aquí entonces restemos 9 por acá
también luego tenemos esta parte de aquí
sería igual a x 3 al cuadrado y más 5
menos 9 es igual a menos 4 así que
cuando esta función es de esta forma
cuando tenemos un punto mínimo bien pues
logra un punto mínimo cuando esta parte
es igual a cero cuando x es igual a
menos 3 y cuando x es igual a menos 3
esto es 0 por lo que f
igual a menos 4 y así que este es el
vértice y esta es la respuesta a en
nuestra pregunta número 39 el vértice
sería menos 3,4 así que problema 40 bien
nos está pidiendo la gráfica nos pide el
problema 40 la gráfica de x sobre 2 al
cuadrado menos menos sobre 2 al cuadrado
y esto es una hipérbole y hace sentido
pues esto más bien sería sobre 3 y esto
será una hipérbola y todo esto igual a 1
y por supuesto que es una hipérbole
entonces cuál es la parte de la ecuación
que representan las síntomas de la
gráfica y una vez más hay algunas
fórmulas que la gente a veces recuerda o
memoriza pero puedes tener la intuición
sobre esto así que veamos qué pasa
cuando x se aproxima
infinito y menos infinito porque esto es
lo que nos importa acerca de un asunto
está cierto aquí se aproxima la acin
total cuando tenemos valores muy muy
grandes de x y que resulta para valores
tan grandes de iu así que vamos a
reordenar todo un poco y digamos que
tenemos esto de un lado tenemos x sobre
2 al cuadrado y que que esto va a ser
igual al pasar lo que estábamos restando
como suma del otro lado uno más ye sobre
tres al cuadrado
ahora si restamos de ambas partes de la
ecuación 11 tendríamos x sobre 2 al
cuadrado menos 1 igual a 10 sobre 3 al
cuadrado y ahora multiplicamos a ambos
lados de la ecuación por 3 al cuadrado
que es lo mismo que mueve entonces
conservando esta forma tendríamos lo
siguiente tendríamos a elevar al
cuadrado esta parte sería x cuadrada
sobre 4 menos uno igual a ye cuadrada
sobre 9 y ahora si si multiplicamos
ambas partes de la ecuación por 9
entonces tendríamos que ye cuadrada es
igual a 9 cuartos por equis cuadrada
menos 9 muy bien y todo esto hay que lo
realizando tan lejos como podamos llegar
con un poco de álgebra y cuando pensamos
en las cintas son puntos en la gráfica
que nunca se alcanzarán pero que
estaremos cerca de por lo que tenemos
que pensar acerca de qué pasa cuando es
muy grande y x también es muy grande
bueno tan grande como x sea conforme x
se aproxime a infinito y tú aprenderás
todo esto en cálculo respecto a los
límites pero es realmente intuitivo el
concepto entonces cuando x tiende a
infinito
este término ye cuadrada se aproxima a
nueve cuartos de x cuadrada puesto que
este 9 que estamos restando no es tan
significativo como esa expresión de x
cuadrada así que a la hora que sacamos
raíz
de esto tenemos que ya se aproxima o
puede ser igual a más menos tres medios
de x por lo que una parte de ella va a
ser igual a tres medios de x y la otra
igual a menos tres medios de x y de
hecho esta es la respuesta a y bueno
ahora yendo conforme a las instrucciones
para graficar lo es un tanto intuitivo
pues nosotros ya sabemos cuáles son las
cintas y el vértice pero pensemos en
cómo lo grafica díaz y si nosotros lo
realizamos recuerda que estamos
aprendiendo y se trata de esto entonces
sólo para evaluarlo hagamos un pequeño
dibujo digamos que tenemos el eje de las
equis y el eje de las es formando mi
herramienta de línea ahora realizando la
sin tota tenemos que una es tres medios
de equis y la otra menos tres medios y
equis por lo que se verían de esta forma
y ahora hay que figurar nos la hipérbola
abrirá hacia estos lados o abrirá hacia
arriba y hacia abajo entonces decimos ok
cuando es igual
hoy es igual a 0 nos queda x medios
igual a más menos 1 cierto entonces x
medios es igual a más menos 1 por lo que
puedes decir que tenemos por aquí menos
1 y acá más 1 y podemos decir que
intersectan en x y pasa esto cuando es
igual a 0 pero qué pasa cuando x es
igual a cero cuando x es igual a cero
después podrías decir que tienes que
menos de medios al cuadrado es igual a
algo positivo y al hacer esto obtendrías
algo con números imaginarios lo cual no
es razonable para nuestro tipo de
problema que queremos por eso podemos
dibujar nuestra gráfica de la hipérbola
de esta forma abriría hacia los lados y
ahora pasemos al siguiente problema
problema 41 cuál de las siguientes
ecuaciones representa una hipérbola y
déjame copiar esto
pero espera más bien cuál de las
siguientes representa una parábola es la
pregunta esta es una versión muy pequeña
no creo que la puedas ver entonces
déjame hago una versión más grande ahí
está ahí está más grande entonces la
pregunta es cuál de estas es una
parábola y veamos que la primera es un
círculo la primera ecuación es un
círculo luego si vamos a nuestra segunda
ecuación tenemos que esto sería igual a
una elipse pues se están sumando estas
partes de aquí e iguales a 1 y si
estuvieran restando será la hipérbola
que es el caso que tenemos en el inciso
d
ahora yendo a esta parte quizás no será
forma convencional de una parábola pero
veamos lo siguiente veamos que a
despejar x es igual a un cuarto
por get cuadrada y a la hora de
dibujarlo nuestra gráfica de dicha
parábola abriría de esta forma entonces
no es una forma convencional de la
parábola pero la respuesta correcta es
el inciso c y muy bien ahora sí pasemos
a nuestro siguiente problema tenemos que
nuestro problema 42 nos dice lo
siguiente ellos nos dan esta ecuación y
lo que quieren que contestemos es que
cuál es la forma estandarizada de la
ecuación de la cónica siguiente
esencialmente lo que ellos quieren es
que completemos el cuadrado con las
equis y las guías correspondientes que
nos dan x menos algo al cuadrado sobre
alguna constante más o menos que menos
salva al cuadrado sobre alguna otra
constante por lo que hagamos eso vamos a
agrupar primero nuestros términos de las
x que es x cuadrada menos 16
es más algo menos tenemos que es menos 5
y el cuadrada pero vamos a sacar nuestro
signo de menos entonces por aquí nos
queda 5 y el cuadrado más 30 y más o
menos algo y menos 9 que esto está
constante que nos quedaba y todo esto
igual a cero ahora si vamos primero a
ver si podemos simplificar un poco más
factor hicimos nuestro número cuatro de
este lado por lo que nos queda x
cuadrada menos 4 x más algo menos de
este lado factorizar y amos nuestro
número 5 entonces nos quedaría cuadrada
más 6 más algo y esto y sumamos de ambos
lados de la ecuación 9 por lo que nos
queda que todo esto es igual a 9 y ahora
sí vamos a completar nuestro cuadrado de
este lado por lo que la mitad de 4 es 2
y 2 al cuadrado es 4 entonces por aquí
tenemos nuestro número 4 por lo que tú
en realidad no está sumando simplemente
4 de este lado de la ecuación pues si te
das cuenta al multiplicarlo por el de
afuera está sumándole 16 entonces
sumamos 16 del lado derecho y
completando el cuadrado de nuestro lado
de esta parte la mitad de seysses 3 al
cuadrado es 9 y de igual forma no está
simplemente sumando 9 9 por 5 es igual a
45 por lo que vas a sumar del lado
derecho
45 y espera más bien estarás restando
por nuestro signo de menos que afecta
del lado izquierdo y ahora si al
factorizar esto tenemos que es igual a 4
por x menos 2 al cuadrado menos 5 porque
más 3 al cuadrado
y todo esto igual a 9 16 es igual a 25
menos 45 se devela menos 20 espera de
saber si no estoy cometiendo algún error
9 + 16 es 25 y menos 45 es igual a menos
20 en efecto está bien esto es igual a
menos 20
ahora podríamos dividir a ambos lados
entre menos 20 y si es esto
correctamente entonces al dividirlo
entre menos 20 tendríamos que 4 entre
este número es igual a menos un quinto y
mejor lo voy a desarrollar es 44 entre
menos 20 x x menos 2 al cuadrado y de
este lado 5 por más 3 al cuadrado entre
menos 20
igual a 1 y observa como es igual algo
positivo y ahora esto sería igual a ye
más 3 para poner esta parte positiva de
más 3 al cuadrado entre 4 menos
- perdón menos 4 entre 20 es igual a un
quinto entonces arriba nos queda x menos
2 al cuadrado sobre 5 y todo esto igual
a 1 por lo que la respuesta es b la
hipérbole nos vemos en el próximo vídeo